depuis 1996 le dramaturge règne sur
versailles le mois molière à 20 ans 20
ans de souvenirs de spectacles et
d'artistes rassemblés dans une
exposition avec en pièce maîtresse la
première affiche du festival
elle a été réalisé par un étudiant de
l'école des beaux-arts et elle a donc
été reprise pour les deux premières
éditions 96 et 1997 et elle figure le
portrait de molière qui évidemment le
personnage emblématique qui a
constituer le coeur de ce premier
festival et son portrait et sa signature
sont au coeur du tissu urbain un petit
peu comme un manifeste de l'importance
du territoire et de sa population pour
la pérennité et l'identité de ce
festival pas de subi chronologique les
temps forts sont présentés de manière
thématique l'histoire du festival se
découvre à travers costumes et masques
de compagnies en résidence mais aussi
ses sites
la ville au départ en 81 96 n'avaient
pas de lieu de capacités suffisantes
pour accueillir des spectateurs aussi
nombreux et à partir de 1998 l'aide du
château a été extrêmement important
puisque il a mis à disposition de la
ville
la cour de la grande écurie qui est
devenu vraiment sa cour d'honneur une
sorte d' épices en fête du festival dans
laquelle les plus grands spectacles en
majorité d'ailleurs gratuits sont sont
présentés l'exposition est à découvrir
jusqu'à la fin du mois de septembre le
mois molière écrira ensuite un nouveau
chapitre de son histoire